OF THE QUEEN.
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE WATCHING "AT
THIS HOUR."
>>> THANKS FOR BEING HERE,
EVERYBODY, I'M KATE BOLDUAN.
THREE PEOPLE ARE DEAD THIS
MORNINGS.
DOZENS OF OTHERS ARE INJURED
AFTER A SERIES OF TORNADOS
TOUCHED DOWN IN LOUISIANA.
JUST LOOK AT SOME OF THE IMAGES
OF DESTRUCTION THAT ARE COMING
IN.
THE LATEST VICTIM -- THE LATEST
VICTIM ANNOUNCED IS A WOMAN IN
HER 50s WHO DIED WHEN A TORNADO
HIT HER HOME IN ST. CHARLES
PARISH.
IT IS LEAVING OBVIOUSLY
WIDESPREAD DESTRUCTION IN THEIR
WAKE.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO NICK
VALENCIA.
HE'S AT ONE OF THE TOWNS HIT
VERY HARD.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING.
>> Reporter: WE ARE SURROUNDED
BY THE DEVASTATION FROM THE
DEADLY TORNADOS THAT RIPPED
THROUGH THIS COMMUNITY.
NO ONE WAS KILLED HERE IN THIS
COMMUNITY.
BUT THEY WERE SIGNIFICANTLY HIT.
DEVASTATED REALLY BY THIS
TORNADO THAT RIPPED THROUGH THIS
COMMUNITY.
AND YOU COULD SEE THIS HOME,
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM RESIDENTS,
IS THAT THEY REALLY JUST DIDN'T
HAVE THAT MUCH TIME TO PREPARE.
10 TO 15 SECONDS THEY SAID
BEFORE THEY KNEW IT AND THE
TORNADO WAS RIGHT ON TOP OF
THEM.
SOME SAID THAT THEY JUST CAN'T
BELIEVE THEY ESCAPED WITH THEIR
LIVES.
>> IT SHOOK US AND KNOCKED US
DOWN BUT THEN I SEE ALL OF THE
DAMAGE ON THE STREET AND I CAN'T
BELIEVE.
THIS HAPPENED IN EIGHT SECONDS.
>> I JUST HEAR A WHOLE BUNCH OF
BOOMING AGAINST THE WALL AND AS
I'M RUBBING OUT, MY BROTHER RUBS
IN FRONT OF ME AND AS WE'RE
RUNNING, WE JUST HEAR A WHOLE
BUNCH OF BOOM AND THEN
EVERYTHING LIKE WE HEARD OUR
ROOF LIFTING AND HE'S LIFTED OFF
HIS FEET AND HE GRABBED ON TO
THE DOOR FRAME.
>> Reporter: THE RESIDENTS HERE
IN GRETNA THAT WE HAVE SPOKEN
JUST FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T CATCH
A BREAK.
THIS YEAR THEY WERE HIT HARD BY
HURRICANE IDA ONLY TO TAKE WHAT
SEEMS LIKE A DIRECT HIT FROM
THIS TORNADO.
THE RESIDENT HERE IN THIS HOME
TELLS MANY HE THAT THEY HAD JUST
FINISHED RECONSTRUCTING AFTER
THE DAMAGE THAT THEY SUFFERED
FROM HURRICANE IDA.
ONLY FOR THIS TO HAPPEN HERE TO
THEIR HOME.
THEY WERE JUST HERE A SHORT TIME
AGO TAKING OUT BELONGINGS OF
WHAT WAS LEFT ANYWAY, THE WOMAN
WOULD LIVED HERE TELLING ME THAT
SHE'S GRATEFUL THIS MORNING TO
BE ALIVE.
KATE.
>> I MEAN, SOMETHING TO BE
GRATEFUL FOR.
BUT THEY REALLY, THEY CAN'T
CATCH A BREAK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, NICK.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>>> AND THE SEVERE WEATHER
THREAT IS STILL NOT OVER.
THAT SAME STORM SYSTEM THAT IS
SPAWNING THOSE TORNADOS IS
DEVELOPING INTO A NOR'EASTER.
CHAD MYERS IS TRACKING IT FOR US
"AT THIS HOUR."
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO SEE TODAY.
>> WE'RE GOING TO SEE ICE IN THE
MOUNTAINS AND VALLEY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, WEST VIRGINIA AND
VIRGINIA ITSELF.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE RAIN ALONG
THE COAST AND CONTINUE TO SEE
THE POTENTIAL FOR SOME TORNADOS
WITH A TORNADO WATCH OVER PARTS
OF FLORIDA.
I JUST LOOKED AT ALL OF THE
STORMS DOWN THERE, THERE IS A
LOST LIGHTNING BUT RIGHT NOW TO
SPIN.
SO THIS IS WHERE THE SNOW IS
GOING TO TAKE PLACE.
WHERE THE NOR'EASTER, AND THE
COASTAL LOW WILL DEVELOP INTO
TOMORROW.
THEY'LL BE SIGNIFICANT ICING.
ALL OF THE REPORTS FROM ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT TOWNS THAT HAD
ALREADY HAD FREEZING RAIN THIS
MORNING.
WINTER STORM WARN READY IN
EFFECT, SO ARE ICE STORM
WARNINGS.
IT IS GOING INTO UPSTATE NEW
YORK AND A BIGGER STORM FOR NEW
ENGLAND AND CANADA.
AS IT MOVES ON BY, IT SPINS
AROUND AND PIVOTS AND NOTICE HOW
LONG THE SNOW LASTS IN JUST THE
SAME SPOTS.
THERE IS YOUR ICE FORECAST.
THAT IS WHERE IT IS VERY
SLIPPERY.
ESPECIALLY AFTER DARK.
AND THEN FOR THE SNOW, SOME
PRETTY BIG SNOW TOTALS HERE
ACROSS PARTS -- IT COULD BE TWO
TO THREE FEET AND IT IS STILL
SNOWING IN PARTS OF THE DAKOTAS
AND MINNESOTA WITH BLIZZARD
WARNINGS GOING ON THERE.
IT IS NOT OVER FOR THE PEOPLE
OUT HERE.
IT IS JUST BEGINNING FOR THE
NORTHEAST.
>> THANK YOU, CHAD.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>>> LET'S GET BACK NOW TO THE
DEVASTATING TORNADOS.
JOINING ME RIGHT NOW IS BELINDA
CONSTANCE, THE MAY OF GRETNA.
MAYOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU SAID LAST NIGHT YOU SAW
CATASTROPHIC DAMAGE IN THE EARLY
MOMENTS AFTER THE TORNADO
STRUCK.
NOW THAT THE SUN HAS COME UP AND
YOU'RE ABLE TO GET A BETTER
LOOKING WHAT ARE SEEING IN TERMS
OF WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO YOUR
COMMUNITY?
>> WELL, KATIE, UNFORTUNATELY
NOW THAT THE SUN IS UP, IT IS
MORE DEVASTATING THAN INITIALLY
EXPECTED.
THERE ARE MOREHOUSES THAT WILL
PROBABLY HAVE TO BE CONDEMNED
OR -- OR DEMOLISHED BASES ON
SUCH DAMAGE, DEVASTATION ACROSS
THE ENTIRE CITY ON THE NORTH
SIDE OF OUR CITY.
IT IS ABOUT A MILE AND A HALF
STRETCH THAT IS COMPLETELY JUST
INUNDATED WITH DESTRUCTION.
YOU COULD SEE THE LINE OF
DESTRUCTION FROM THE TORNADO AS
PEOPLE DESCRIBED TORNADO AS THEY
MOVE THROUGH AN AREA.
BEHIND ME IS AN EXAMPLE OF THE
DEVASTATION THAT IS LEFT BEHIND.
THIS HOUSE IS STILL STANDING
UNFORTUNATELY.
IT SEEMS TO BE A STRUCTURE THAT
WILL HAVE TO BE DEMOLISHED.
>> MAYOR, IS EVERYONE ACCOUNTED
FOR IN YOUR CITY?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT IS THE
BLESSING AND WE THANK GOD FOR
THAT THIS MORNING AND ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL SUNNY SKIES AND
BEAUTIFUL DAY, WE HAD NO LOSS OF
LIFE.
WE HAD THREE PEOPLE TRANSPORTED
TO A HOSPITAL WITH
NONLIFE-THREATENING INJURIES AND
WERE RELEASED AND WE THANK GOD
FOR THAT THIS MORNING.
AND, YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SAY,
AND WE DID YESTERDAY JUST GAVE
KUDOS TO THE LOCAL MEDIA AND THE
WAY THAT THEY REPORTED THIS
EVENT AND ENCOURAGING AND
ADVISING AND PLEADING WITH
PEOPLE TO TAKE SAFETY IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE SURVIVED IN
BATHTUBS AND INTERIOR CLOSETS.
THIS IS NOT THE PLACE WHERE WE
NORMALLY HAVE TORNADOS.
SO OUR REALITY OF A SAFE HOUSE
IS NOT WHAT IT IS IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY.
BUT PEOPLE SURVIVED IN BATHTUBS
AND SO WE'RE JUST, AS I SAID,
JUST FEELING BLESSED THIS
MORNING IN THE MIDST OF THE
DEVASTATION.
>> I GUESS YOU HAVE TO -- IT IS
THE BEST WAY TO BE, TO COUNTS
THE BLESSINGS IN MOMENTS OF
TRUE, TRUE TRAGEDY.
WHAT IS THE MOST PRESSING ISSUE?
WHAT DO THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY NEED?
>> WE'VE GOT SEVERAL GROUPS OF
PEOPLE, JEFFERSON PARISH IS
WORKING IN CONCERT WITH US,
EVALUATING ALL STRUCTURES,
DETERMINING WHO WILL NEED
TEMPORARY HOUSING.
BILLY NUNGESSER HAS REACHED OUT
TO US AND WORKING ON THE
TEMPORARY HOUSING.
SO THAT IS PRIORITY.
PEOPLE OVER PROPERTY IS PRIORITY
FOR US THIS MORNING IN THE
RECOVERY EFFORT.
AND WE JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO OUR LOCAL PARTNERS WHO
HAS REACHED OUT AND JUST SUCH AN
OUTPOURING FROM OTHER
MUNICIPALITIES THAT HAVE WALKED
THROUGH THIS WALK AND IS
STANDING WITH US AND THROUGH
THIS RECOVERY PROCESS.
>> OUR CORRESPONDENT ON THE
GROUND NICK VALENCIA SPOKE TO A
FAMILY OF THE HOUSE NEAR OR --
BEHIND YOU OR RIGHT NEARBY WHO
SAID THEY REALLY JUST FINISHED
KIND OF PICKING UP THE PIECES
AND PUTTING THINGS BACK TOGETHER
AFTER HURRICANE IDA.
AND NOW THIS.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A COMMUNITY THAT
IS GETTING HIT AND GETTING HIT
AGAIN AND YOU CAN'T GET BACK UP
AGAIN AND CAN'T CATCH, A BREAK,
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM?
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO YOUR
RESIDENTS?
>> IT IS SO HARD TO FACE PEOPLE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THROUGH
TRAGEDY.
RIGHT.
BUT THROUGH IT ALL, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, WE'RE A RESILIENT PEOPLE
AND THIS IS THE TYPE OF THING
THAT DON'T CHOOSE LOCATIONS.
IT IS SPONTANEOUS AND IT
HAPPENED WHEN IT IS LEAST
EXPECTED.
WE'VE NOT HAD A TORNADO THROUGH
THIS CITY IN 70 YEARS.
SO, THIS WAS TOTALLY UNEXPECTED.
WE DON'T LIVE IN A PLACE KNOWN
AS TORNADO ALLEY OR A PLACE THAT
IS PRONE TO TORNADO.
WE PREPARE FOR HURRICANES.
SO THIS IS QUITE UNEXPECTED AND
WE STAND HERE COMMITTED WITH OUR
NEIGHBORS TO GET THROUGH THIS AS
BEST AS WE CAN AS A COMMUNITY
AND WE'RE A STRONG COMMUNITY
WHERE WE'RE A SMALL COMMUNITY,
WE'RE 20,000 PEOPLE STRONG HERE
IN THE CITY OF GRETNA AND WE
STAND WITH EACH OTHER THROUGH
RECOVERY AND THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
DOING THIS MORNING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WELL MAYOR, THANK YOU FOR TAKI